wir sind dumm dumm dumm einfach nur dumm
und warum wir unser Popcorn nicht im
Kino sein sondern in einem leeren
verlassenen Laden gegessen haben das
erzähle ich euch gleich tagsüber war ich
ultra motiviert wir haben insgesamt 8
Säcke Kleidung ausgemistet die wir jetzt
spenden werden das ganze hat mich so
hungrig gemacht dass ich sie mit Porsche
vorbereitet habe ich hatte richtig Lust
drauf nach dem Stall hatte haben seine
Überraschung für mich den Herd Kino
Karten besorgt toller Vorfreude haben
uns Popcorn gegönnt und natürlich Wasser
am Start und waren so richtig glücklich
wir haben so richtig gefreut auf den
neuen Mario und dann kam die traurige
Wendung des Abends die Karten man
einfach 24 Stunden vorher gültig das
heißt wir waren einfach einen ganzen Tag
zu spät die Kasse hatte auch schon
geschlossen also wussten wir nicht was
wir mit uns in unserem Popcorn anfangen
sollen wir haben gesagt ach ja um die
Ecke also gehen wir einfach mal rein und
ich finde es sieht abends einfach
richtig magisch aus wir haben uns
einfach vorgestellt was im Mario Film
vorkommen würde bestimmt ein Rennen
machen mit Luigi und dann wenn du
bestimmt ganz lustiges sehen vorkommen
und ja Fantasie wir müssen auch lustig